bracket notation is a way to get a
character that's at a specific index
within a string javascript doesn't start
counting at one like humans do it starts
at zero this is referred to as
zero-based indexing here we've assigned
the first name variable to the string Bo
so with this string you can get the
value of the first letter of the string
by using so if we run that we see B in
the console so we have the first name
variable and then we use these brackets
and inside the brackets we put the index
so index 0 is B because we start
counting at 0 but we can also change
this to 1 and then you'll see in the
console we have E because E is index 1 a
is index 2 and u is index 3 and if you
want to get the last character of the
string you can just subtract 1 from the
strings length like this instead of
putting one in here I'm going to paste
in first name that length minus 1 so
then you just automatically get the last
character in the string which is in this
case is you you can also get any other
character from the end so if you want to
get this second-to-last character you
just do minus 2 and then we're going to
get a you can also get the third to last
carrot or the fourth the last character
it you just do the string dot length and
then minus how many characters you want
to go back from in JavaScript string
values are immutable which means that
they cannot be altered once created so
if I want to try to set the character in
index 0 to Q well you can't do that you
cannot change individual characters in a
string because the strings are immutable
but I can set the first name variable to
a whole new string so you can see here
I've set the first name variable to
Quincy and I've logged this with this
new string here but we did not
technically alter the string Bo up here
we just set the variable to an entirely
new string well thanks for watching my
name is Bo Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good